Only few companies are big enough to
supply the needs of an entire market.
Even the large ones must break down
the total demand into segments and
choose those that the company's
best equipped to handle.
Market segmentation is marketing
strategy that involves dividing a broad
target market into subsets of consumers
who have common needs, wants,
demand, or characteristics.
You'll be developing a marketing
strategy that targets the individuals in
your chosen segment.
You can learn the basics of it in
the book that become the bible for
startups 25 years ago.
And it's still valid.
Crossing The Chasm, by Geoffrey Moore.
Let's meet Geoffrey Moore himself
to learn what he has to say
about market segmentation.
>> Hi, so my name's Geoffrey Moore.
I live in Silicon Valley.
I'm a business author, I'm a member
of a venture capital firm, and
I consult and
advise technology companies, largely.
Entrepreneurs tend to have
visions of global domination, and
in that model you want to
segment the whole world.
Because eventually the whole world
is going to buy your product,
it's just a question of
who's going to buy it first.
So, I think the whole world
thing is a great fantasy and
it keeps you going at night and
on the weekends, but
eventually if you're going to
actually light the fire.
You know when you light a fire,
you don't want to run a match up and
down under a very big log,
you're just going to burn your fingers.
What you want to do when you light
a fire is you get some kindling and
then you get some crumpled up paper,
and you get the match.
And you hold the match in one and
only one place until it
starts to burst into flame.
Then the flame can grow.
But so, the key thing with
the segmentation at the beginning for
an entrepreneur is, where are you
going to hold the match and
how long are you going to hold
it in place until it lights?
And sometimes you put it,
holding in the wrong place.
You're holding it under a brick and
bricks do not burn, right?
Okay.
So, you've got to move the match but,
what you don't want to do is just
continually moving it back and forth.
And entrepreneurs who are in love with
their product have a very tough time
with this problem.
Entrepreneurs who are in love with their
customer, do not have this problem.
>> Okay, so how do we start this fire?
Let's explore the different
types of segmentation.